okay everyone sorry I can't remember but
I'm first randomly for them luckily for
luckily for that Mike still here
so we have to talks on this in this
section what chocolate first time is
white pork chops give it a nice cut off
it means I think that direction right
it's election Carter candy yes okay so
okay so let's start with something that
we hopefully all know about so I guess
there's the selection problem let us the
following you're given a set of school
function
why from datasets to reels which satisfy
the property that I equals 1 through ok
so there's some finite number of score
functions we usually assume that you
guys have sensitivity 1 which means for
any two data sets you ID minus Qi D
Prime that our neighbors let's say about
it by one we make a sensitivity
assumption and the selection problem
asks can I find the best of these QX
right private algorithm kind of I think
next best here that say means I want to
maximize the score function and this is
a problem that we know how to solve in
multiple ways we can use the exponential
mechanism or the my Z maximum and I
guess what we'll be doing today is kind
of give a big generalization of a
generalization of this kind of razor so
let me start by motivating the problem
so here's one possible motivation so
let's say I want to solve a standard
statistical test ever I have a set of
numbers so each di is nets in 0 1 my
goal is to
so let's say this di is the location of
a person on a beach and I want to put my
ice cream cart so that people don't have
to walk too much so I want to find the
media I want to minimize some overall I
of next year
so X is the output that I'm looking for
I want to minimize the sum of absolute
values of the distances this is the
median problem how do you solve the
medians problem privately
so this is a very well studied problem
in differential privacy and there are
multiple algorithms to do it right so so
this is not a very insensitive function
so I can't use the usual techniques like
adding adding noise proportion to
sensitivity but we can for example use
the smooth sensitivity sensitivity
framework I can also actually just use
the exponential mechanism this is a
literate score function it could be that
I believe that there is actually a lot
of people who will be close to the
median on the beach so I could use
what's known as a proposed test release
framework which mean
well postulates that there's non-trivial
density right around the median and if
that's the case then the median is not
very sensitive and I guess this actually
takes a parameter which is my guess for
the density at the median this is really
a family of habit
which of these is the best
for for each of these I can almost
surely come up with the data set where
one of them will be significantly better
than the other if my goal is to actually
optimize this core function privately
it's not clear what I should do there's
a number of algorithms there's a number
of hyper parameters for one of those
algorithms I could actually also just
run a private mean algorithm that's
another option my belief my median is
close to the mean this is actually good
so I guess here is a setting where
there's a number of algorithms I don't
know which one to pick
so what I could do is I could say well
let me run each of them each of them
gives me an answer so let me call these
m eyes each mi gives me an X to the
point between 0 & 1 and I could actually
compute this score function
so this X is differentially private
given an X I can compute its score the
score is insensitive so I could add
noise to the score and get a private
estimate of the score so each mi gives
me in this case an answer which is X and
a score which I'll call Q and I'll
assume that I've added some Laplace
noise to the score to make it private I
have a number of algorithms each
algorithms give me an X and a Q on any
given data set so now I have a number of
options of X and Q values my goal was to
maximize Q maybe I can just run the
exponential mechanism and pick the best
of these
and that seems very tempting
unfortunately it's not private
so if I generate each of these em eyes
okay sorry
so I'm in the setting where the number
of I want to pay a total privacy cost
that does not increase with the number
of options I could easily if I have K
options I could easily run all K of them
publish all of them and then privately
pick amongst them yeah right in fact I
can publicly pick the best of them but
I'm playing a privacy cost of epsilon
times K and my goal in this talk would
be to not pay that factor of K imagine K
being very large
good so so there's an abstraction of
this problem now in so this is what I'll
call the meta selection problem instead
of score functions
I use epsilen base for the privacy of
the base mechanisms
and now hm I will output not just a
score but some object are think of X as
the as the answer the actual median
model in some cases and R is the is how
good this this option is on this data
set and now I've replaced sensitivity by
just this differential privacy adoption
this is and now again I want to
privately pick the best time I want to
do as well as the best of my median
alder
in general I'll have kind of so I guess
I want my privacy to be almost as good
as any one of them I want to have good
utility and I also care about run time
I'll also care about how many Oracle
calls to the base Mis do I have to make
so those will be the three criteria
I want to optimize these three criteria
find the mechanism which makes so I
guess before I can actually define this
problem I need to define what does best
mean when i was comparing real numbers
it was obvious what the best was the
largest was the best
now I'm comparing distributions each ma
gives me a distribution if I have this
distribution versus this distribution
it's not necessarily clear which one is
better
and I guess there's many possible
definitions for best share the
definition I'll be using today will be
just look at the median of each mi
so
let me define tau star to be the max
overall I million of the distribution so
I guess I'm abusing notation here a
little bit whenever I think of MIT as a
number I'll really be talking about the
second coordinate of it first coordinate
is some arbitrary abstract object but
I'll still use my of T and I really mean
am i D
the second quarter yep Cubase refers to
this co-wrote so so to the Macanese man
included this corner or yes exactly so
epsilon based so this this mechanism
outputs both model and a score I want
this whole output to be differentially
private differently considering the
actual privacy of the mechanism at you
want three points so you want to be
prevent the smaller cities since it's
not the yes none of this move
I have to add in so if I were to for
example apply this here I'll add some
noise to be to the actual computed score
and I'll add in the privacy cost of that
to epsilon bass and I guess my utility
would be kind of want to say do as well
yeah very busy posting them report
amazing max it
so if you were to now just compute the
arc max of the QIS and report it that is
not going to be the French dependent
there are examples okay so I guess if
you want to argue about privacy of this
mechanism report noisy max or the
expansion mechanism we are running it on
a set of options which are the outputs
of m1 through MK which themselves depend
on the data for report no Z max to be
private the base distribution the set of
candidates that I am selecting from has
to be a public set now the data set is
not affect affecting not just what's my
likelihood of picking this amongst a set
of candidates it's actually affecting
the set of candidates and it's not hard
to show that if you just do that
that's Absalom que differentially
private and no better
more questions
but if this if the score was also law
sensitivity would things work no just
the fact that my options are all
generated from the data makes Mikko so
even in the case of median where my
score is actually a low sensitivity
function we can't just publish this yeah
could you get an improvement by
minimizing it more carefully music
something my party theater epsilon Delta
lies No
excellent Delta yes but I will still get
some dependence on K so you can prove
something like you get epsilon log K
over Delta Gamma Delta dot PP we don't
want to pay any dependence okay so you
will your final goal here be appear
needy uh yes I guess we'll have multiple
goals some results will have P OTP some
benevolent entity
good so why is this interesting so let
me just give some examples so so first
considered first I'll argue that this
generalizes the exponential matrix so
suppose I can do this where my privacy
is order epsilon and I get utility like
this if I'm in the exponential mechanism
setting I can define my mi to be I
doesn't depend on the data
this is differentially private by the
properties of the Laplace mechanism so
this is a differential private mechanism
that outputs two objects if I can do
this let's compute what our store is now
star in this case
is is the median the median of this is
is Qi so the largest median is just max
over I of Qi
so my guarantee will say I'm getting
something that's almost as good but what
I'm outputting is is a pair I twiddle Q
twiddle and Q twiddle is equal to Qi
twiddle + Laplace noise so so I know
that Q twiddle is at least now start by
my utility guarantee and it's at most Q
I twiddle of P plus log 1 over K will be
don't be negative
no it's smaller the largest youth but it
can be is the actual Q plus the largest
of the Laplace processes that I added
I'm adding kala plus vs. all of them
with higher probability are at most log
K over
which translates to saying that my Qi
twiddle the score of the I twiddle data
output is the optimum - something like
log K over Epsilon it is exactly the
kind of guarantee you'll get from sort
of algorithms predetermine the strings
in this case they are in general they
would be so right now my I was
independent of data I want I'll actually
solve this problem and this first
coordinate actually doesn't it can
depend heavily on the data like in the
case of the medium you could do that
but it's harder to write we haven't even
if you rerun it you will get something
that's Qi twiddle and there's no
guarantee that Qi twiddle is going to be
not have noise if you outwardly can be
at least can be as small as this -
Lockyer Epsilon and there's no getting
around it I mean the exponential
mechanism is optimal so you can't beat
this lock you vector
here's another application there's this
beautiful generalizable exponential
mechanism of cosmic violence myth we are
they asked the question what happens if
different key wires have different
sensitivity here I had assumed
sensitivity one but if each cure has its
own different sensitivity I'll add noise
that's proportional to the sensitivity
and just for fun I will actually
subtract rocky over beta times si
where's what this abstraction does is
that ensures that with high probability
this thing is no larger than Gy
so here I twiddle will now be smaller
than qi q hi but this median now is off
by a log here where beta times si
perhaps so now I've gotten a guarantee
that the out I twiddle that I output has
quality at least as good as the best -
something that depends only on the
sensitivity of the best this is a bit
little empty that trust-fund accordance
with get su here you get it more
directly and I guess you can now derive
a generalized just further
generalization mechanism where the know
as you add is proportional to the smooth
sensitivity instead of the worst case
sensitivity of it size and essentially
the same argument works
my explanation mechanism using the same
approach you can essentially derive
other generalizations of the exponential
mechanism such as once where you assume
some gap between the best and the second
best or the gaps or a zoom gap somewhere
between the gate and the k plus one
that's all of those kind of follow from
this here is the main application that
kind of motivated this work is called
optimization which I guess is
essentially this application extended to
machine learning so we can design
machine learning algorithms like nauseas
GD which give us good guarantees have
differential privacy but they involved
some hyper parameters you have to set
the learning rate you have to set the
number of steps you run it for maybe
you're using momentum so forever you
have a parameter you get some mechanism
so basically if you each setting of
hyper parameters gives you a different
differentially private mechanism but you
now you want to select and you actually
strongly believe that one of those
helper parameter settings is going to
give you something good you want to
compete with the best of those hyper
parameters without paying the privacy
cost of all of them
so what you can do is define mi of D to
be
so now you care about both the model and
its accuracy let's say we compute the
accuracy on a separate validation set so
I will run my n train with certain hyper
parameters H I on the train part of the
data set and then I compute the accuracy
of this model
on an validation set oh let's say I had
some that last night to this
who thinks out that I output clearly
this is differentially private because
I've added the train gets differential
privacy from the fact that this
mechanism is differentially private the
validation gets differential privacy
because I've added the classifiers and
now I want to compete with the best of
these I want to get accuracy as not as
possible and then if you just plug
things in basically you would get that
you compete well with the best type of
errupting so I guess let's say this is
0-1 accuracy it's a classification task
so this is kind of the common one over n
yeah
so I guess usually a validation sets are
large enough that this is really
negligible and we won't really worry
about that
actually the dominant term will be 1
over square root of that that just comes
from the fact that my validation set
accuracy and my population accuracy are
going to differ by a little bit so when
I apply this the kind of guarantees I
get will also depend and actually this
is also the application that really
motivates why this is very important
when I'm training these large machine
learning models training each model
takes a long time if I have to run each
model not many many times that's not
going to be practical step t2 maybe
aggregator is somewhere again boosting I
don't know this is the kind of ground to
select the best but if it into something
that obligates there and compete with
the best so that would be great we don't
know how to do that privately ok I guess
because I mean I guess in general each
model is going to encode a little bit of
information if you kind of put them
together you can't really publish that
model because that contains all of the
models and that will only be able to
link a differentially private we want to
just publish one of these models the one
that's the best one
good so let me give you a little bit of
history so this kind of problem has been
looked at before in some disguised form
there's an old paper of gupta Katrina on
open Gupta Katrina Liggett Frank
McSherry Alan Roth and myself from oh
nine where we looked at a different
problem we looked at what we call the
private reputation theorem but if you
just kind of apply that framework what
you get is that if you know the towel
that you are aiming for then you can get
something like two epsilon base you
essentially compete with that towel if
it's actually a correct estimate and
your run time is essentially something
like order K squared
so you need to make case quite Oracle
codes if you're doing is want to do as
medallist
there's another work bayano pom Frank
and myself from 11:00 at from 2011 that
was never published but it kind of looks
at a related problem it has a different
utility model it also gets twice epsilon
base cute but has a different kind of
utility and I guess what I'll be showing
you today is a new algorithm this is
joint work with Jing Chang Liu who is
present here yes there it was my intern
last year and I guess really get okay so
I guess we'll give a simple algorithm
that gives something like three times
epsilon base again you don't need to
okay sorry so I guess here this is
dominated by the previous
a little
so sorry cows to maximum yeah that was
the quality I might let I'm aiming for
if I actually knew the quality I could
do something in general we don't
necessarily more the quality don't want
to kind of pay for some kind of binary
search to find the stuff so yeah so I
guess I should not send you just work by
turbo and Chaudhary or Jordanian turbo
that looked at her parameters parameter
search but they made significant
assumptions on these mechanisms so that
already you have a significant stability
here in particular I guess we try to
apply that to our deep learning setting
and defect
so
so I guess I'll describe this result and
then I'll say a little bit about some of
the other results in the paper okay so
let me define a slightly related problem
which I'll call private reputation
theorem which basically says I have yeah
so yeah so I guess this thing needs to
be a private quantity however it is
computed in the case when it's an
accuracy of a zero one classification
laws I can compute it this way if it's a
different kind of accuracy guarantee I
would still need to figure out a way to
make that differentially private and I
guess if if this quantity is not
differentially private this is kind of a
hopeless problem we can't really hope it
works so let me define this problem that
I call private reputation
it's time for very closely related
problem here now I'm given just one
mechanism M which is less the epsilon
base and I'll define define tau P to be
the 1 minus 5th percentile of M so this
is the maximum
why such that probability
[Music]
they go pee and one person and this is
the 99% time oh do you mechanisms how
this is like a median just a quartile
and I guess my goal is to
I'm given P I want to privately compete
with the one - beer for sometime there
is a problem the value work is why is
the return you have to return both X and
Q yeah X so M returns an X and a Q just
like in the previous case and I want to
find an x QP R such that Q is kind of in
the top 1% Oh this distribution so I
guess this is kind this is typically the
problem that we looked at in in this
work for different reasons why is this
related so if I can solve this problem I
can define my M to be the uniform
distribution over the M is if I take the
mechanism which is the uniform
distribution over m is it's obviously
still differentially private and just
make choosing randomly between
differentially private mechanisms and
the 1 over 2k its percentile of that
mixed mechanism is going to be at least
as large as the largest median so if I
can solve this problem I'll be able to
solve that problem by just doing this
black box
what depends on the people right there I
think time will depend a bit yep okay so
I guess I don't have much time let me
give you so if you're trying to solve
this problem kind of the simplest thing
you may want to do is to say following
I'll start with the empty set I just
want to see well let's think of PS
roughly 1 over P
I run this mechanism on my data set many
times and then I've tried it many times
and then I'll just output maximum fare
from it
I'll just run it a bunch of times and
then pick the best one so this is kind
of the simplest thing you would think of
if we were solving the private problem
known privately this of course doesn't
work this only gives you absolutely
differential privacy this is one of
several many many things that don't work
but here's something that works so
here's a slight modification
at a sample T from a geometric
distribution parameter
instead of picking a fixed D I'll pick T
at random and then just run the sunset
and theorem is that this discrete
mechanism is three absalom days private
it outputs the
present I'll accept actually let me do a
little bit more let me set it up beta
here beta some constant less than one
then this probability will be at least 1
minus beta this algorithm will succeed
with probability later an expected
runtime is roughly 1 over beta
and so if I think of the setting I cared
about where P was 1 over K I'm getting
roughly K over beta runtime and I'm
compute competing with the best meeting
so I guess I don't have time to prove
this but actually proving this is is
very I mean these two you can probably
already see immediately proving this you
couldn't give it as a homework exercise
in your grad probability class it's
actually you know can pretty much write
down the expressions for the probability
of any outcome for this algorithm and
four lines of Daybreak manipulation show
you that this satisfies three excellent
it can also put a because you can just
put I inside X so am I can always output
its name so you cannot put I'm there's
some more results in the paper we can
handle if you're starting algorithms are
epsilon delta differentially private you
can get absolute delta versions of these
serums this algorithm kind of has a
potentially unbounded run time you can
get a version which has a finite run
time you pay in a small delta actually
you don't even need to pay in a small
data you paint a small failure
probability and i guess one more
interesting result that's in the paper
is the following so so the sparse vector
technique can be thought of as it's a
version of the exponential mechanism
which can work online the exponential
mechanisms i need to get all my options
before hand the sparse vector tech
technique say give me the options one at
a time but it asks for the threshold
that you're shooting for
so the exponential vitalism competes
with the best this part Spectre
technique competes with the value that
you ask it to compete with but now can
do it online and it will say yes at the
first step where where that value is
exceeded we can kind of extend this far
Specter technique to this this this
matter setting where the base things are
not score functions but differentially
private mechanisms the algorithm there
is sexually simple but it's messy the
run times are not linear very far from
them but it can give you some kind of
results as a black box so for example is
Rachel yesterday showed us a very nice
algorithm that that in the offline
setting can given a sequence decide if
some change has happened if you change
one detection in the offline setting and
you can convert that algorithm to an
online algorithm in a completely black
box way by using the sparse vector
technique now applied to arbitrary
mechanisms so I guess I mean Rachel
already did that for her mechanism but
for that she had to exploit specific
properties of the mechanism this is
saying you give me any differentially
private mechanism I can convert it into
a into a online version without being
anything
some quick open questions one time here
is K over beta if I didn't care about
privacy I can do something like a LAN
one over beta we don't know if that's
needed this constant three can be
improved to two at the cost of larger
runtime and more complicated algorithm
it would be nice to reduce that to two
with a simple efficient algorithm to is
kind of optimal so we can't hope to I
mean for some definition of optimal so
we can't hope to beat that and I guess
yeah this power specter technique that I
mentioned is not particularly efficient
getting a simple version of that would
be great
[Applause]
since use the motivation of Piper
parameter selection and you said other
things that work did you find that this
is actually really effective we haven't
tried a tip but I mean I guess it's a
very simple algorithm which is
essentially saying randomly try a whole
bunch of fiber parameters and see which
one is the best that is kind of one of
the best algorithms in practice even on
privately so I see no reason why this
shouldn't work but there is a natural
interesting open question there are some
settings where more we're smarter hyper
parameters are algorithms unaffected
like these evasion optimization invasion
search based algorithms I'm told there
is a paper that does differentially
private page in search I guess I need to
look at it I haven't looked at it but I
guess more generally sometimes we do
have adaptive hyper parameter search
algorithms getting differentially
package versions of those would be